we still on the same [ __ ] because draco
didn't die you know shoot out no crazy
street [ __ ] like how the [ __ ] we be on
you know what i'm saying he died at work
you know what i'm saying at his job you
know what i'm saying [ __ ] make it seem
like oh he died on something
no he died at work where he felt more
comfortable mm-hmm we didn't die on the
streets and he didn't die on the street
was there any like when you guys uh got
to that show was there any idea that
there was any like like like you guys
said you're at work we wasn't worried
about it we went to work you know what
i'm saying we wasn't caring who was
there what was that we just went to work
you know i'm saying dracula's gonna pick
up his money if it was just me him and
one security he wasn't giving a [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying would you say that
the
backstage area was a bit
unorganized for five minutes that's what
i mean like lack of security security
like what do you mean i know security if
you ask me [ __ ] i ain't seen